-Singer Britney Spears's father,
Jamie Spears,
said he'd be willing
to eventually step down
as her conservator
amid public pressure
and after Britney's new lawyer,
Mathew Rosengart,
filed a petition
to have him removed
from controlling her finances,
which means --
-Wow, good for her.
-I'm sorry. This is one of
my writers, Dina Gusovsky.
Dina, what's the matter?
Are you not happy
that Britney Spears
may finally be removed
from her conservatorship?
-No, I'm thrilled for her.
-Disappointed that it took this
long for people to believe her?
-I mean, yeah,
but that's not it.
-So then what's the problem?
-How come Britney Spears
found a nice Jewish lawyer
and I still can't?
-Oh, geez.
-Seth, if you think being in
a conservatorship is difficult,
try being a single Jewish woman
approaching 35.
And yet you don't see Hulu
and "The New York Times"
joining forces to make
an Emmy-nominated documentary
about me.
-Dina, I think
it's important to note
that Britney Spears's new lawyer
is representing her.
She's not dating
this Jewish lawyer.
-Well, neither am I.
I'm not dating
any Jewish lawyer.
Seth, how do you think
relationships start?
At work.
Trust me, it's a good thing
you're married and "not Jewish."
Otherwise, you would eventually
have to break up with me
or fire me.
And we all know
I'm irreplaceable as a writer.
-Dina, I know dating
must be hard,
but you have plenty of time left
to find someone.
-Seth, even J-Lo had to resort
to getting back together
with her ex.
I mean, what hope is there
for those of us
with uninsurable asses?
-Look, Dina, maybe you could
broaden your search.
Do you have to marry
a Jewish lawyer?
-No, not necessarily.
I mean, there's really only one
who meets my qualifications
anyway, and he's already taken.
-Let me guess.
Are we back to talking about
Second Gentleman Doug Emhoff?
-You know it.
Look at this guy.
He's got me in a high holi-daze
all year-round.
-Well, Dina,
I guess it's too bad
that he's already married
to Vice President Kamala Harris.
-I don't care
if he's into goyim.
I'd still destroy him.
-Look, I get the fact
that he's a successful lawyer
and he holds a historic
and powerful office.
But do you actually find him
to be that much of a stud?
-Uh, yeah, I do.
I mean, just seeing his photo
gets me all excited.
Seth, I don't want
to get too graphic.
-No, Dina, please don't.
-But it's a hot August day
in Panty Town,
and the neighborhood kids just
turned on the fire hydrant.
-Dina, I will turn off
your microphone.
-Who cares?
There's no audience.
And these guys love it.
Am I right?
-Do not encourage the crew!
And, crew,
do not encourage Dina!
-Look, Seth, maybe I can
be happy for Britney
and her new Jewish lawyer.
I mean, she and I
do have a lot in common.
-Oh, really?
-♪ Because I'm not
that innocent ♪
[ Laughter ]
-Let's make sure
Jennifer Hudson left.
[ Laughter ]
Dina Gusovsky, everybody.